a new Iron person a possible secret
villain and neymore earning his wings
what are the secrets are hiding in the
new trailer for Black Panther wakanda
forever
56 seconds into the trailer we get a
great look at Neymar in all his Winged
Foot Glory he's introduced via a
voiceover from umbaku and will
supposedly serve as the film's primary
antagonist Marvel Studios decided to
give the character a Mayan spin for his
MCU introduction Neymar's updated look
for the MCU looks incredible and the
inclusion of his winged feet is enough
to get any fans of the Submariner
excited do not call him general or King
they called him
the feather serpent Court the trailer
also makes it clear that killing him
would risk Eternal war in the comics
wakanda and Atlantis almost never see
eye to eye and it looks like wakanda
forever perfectly sets up that
relationship Marvel Comics introduced
Neymar in 1939 in Marvel comics issue 1
from them publisher timely Comics he is
a son of an Atlantean princess although
due to his human father he doesn't share
the same blue tinted skin as most
atlanteans in the comics he's also
usually the king of Atlantis though his
MCU debut will include some changes
according to name or actor to notewerta
his powers include underwater breathing
superhuman strength and the ability to
fly using the wings on his feet because
of his first publication date he is
sometimes considered Marvel's first
mucent interestingly wetter confirmed to
Empire that the character is a mutant in
wakanda Forever
Neymar isn't the only new comic
character popping up in wakanda Forever
in a quick shot in the trailer for Black
Panther wakanda forever viewers can see
none other than Riri Williams who in the
comics is known as ironheart this is a
fitting character to be introduced in
Black Panther wakanda forever
considering that the mantle of black
panther has also changed hands in the
comics Williams has a genius level
intellect by H5 she crafts her own Iron
Man suit after reverse engineering
pieces from an Iron Man armor design
chances are Williams is constructing her
own armor suit from whatever Tony Stark
armor she's been able to find which
shouldn't be too hard since it's not
like he's been super careful with them
by the end of the trailer we see
Williams einhardt Persona in flight so
it doesn't look like it will take her
long to step up to the proverbial Iron
Man plate
we get a small glimpse of tatuma in the
first teaser for black panther wakanda
forever where he appears on a bridge
ready to fight what looks to be Okoye
we're getting a better look at that
moment in the trailer where the villain
launches himself into the air before
slamming down on the bridge artuma's
inclusion in the phase 4 film is very
important as a character is the arch
nemesis of Neymar in the comics we fully
expect to see a battle for power between
the two the history between Neymar and
artumar is lengthy and there are any
number of stories we could see adapted
into the new movie with Neymar being
more of an anti-hero than an outright
villain we might see oursuma play a
little more of the bad guy rather than
his Nemesis counterparts a tumor plans
to flood the surface world in the comics
and since we see wakanda getting fleshed
out in the teaser perhaps it was all his
doing and not Neymar's
and finally we get a black panther
throwback in the trailer's final moments
when the new mantle wearer does set
superhero Landing from high above while
it's not fully confirmed in the preview
who is behind the mask all Clues and
recent Lego releases point to it being
to Charla's sister shuri the only
question is how she will handle the new
role and the throne that could
potentially come with it as Neymar says
at the beginning of the trailer only the
most broken people can be great leaders
seems like with t'challa gone sure he
would fit the bill with that in mind
though how long will it be in the film
before she steps into the role and takes
up the legendary mantle and will it be
enough to take on whoever setting
Atlantis and wakanda against each other
we'll have to wait and find out when
Black Panther wakanda forever arrives in
theaters on November 11th
foreign